you're lying i swear i'm not lying i'm
not well i'm okay i'm lying a little bit
but i'm a producer and that's what i do
and i will have your money in full i
promise you you got 72 hours after that
i choked you to death
come on i'm not an idiot you haven't
painted the most accurate portrait of
our investor
all right we've been in trouble before
we always find a way out
it's all over the street you need money
why don't you guys come by this set
frank pierce is gonna be there excuse me
mr pierce
i'm so sorry to bother you i get your
autograph
frank pierce was insured for five
million dollars this gun baby he doesn't
shoot a frame
of film and he makes five million
dollars well how would you felt it all
you had to show for it was a
lousy insurance check look i got a scam
what do you mean a scam we make it look
like we're actually gonna be putting
together a movie
we heavily insured a star will do his
own stunts you took montana yeah that's
took montana what are you doing duke
montana come on daily game russian relax
you are perfect for this particular part
i really connected to the story yeah but
duke it's like western you know it's
very masculine
congratulations
bang we kill him in a stunt he's dead
and then we're rich
we're rich
duke montana if he were alive right now
i know he would be saying
where's that damn horse here duke
my god you're alive you don't know this
guy he's got like nine lives
it's not that hard to kill somebody
we're shooting this fantastic roper's
scene
it's gonna be a real killer do one for
you that'd be six foot under up on boot
hill right
these people are ready to die for you
that's the best choice
what kind of a human being are you well
i'm a producer
[Music]
how is it a guy making a million dollar
movie don't have a better car
i don't believe in ostentatious
flamboyance
you